étranger
[Music]
poisson
ours polaire tout ce sur quoi nous mettons la main
est
[Music] l'
une des communautés les plus touchées par le
changement climatique dans tout le Canada si nous
ne faisons rien à ce sujet très rapidement,
nous pourrions nous heurter à une catastrophe et si
nous devons déménager d'ici nous
ne saurions pas je n'ai aucune idée d'où nous allons
aller à
Vivian pommes de terre
étranger
[Musique]
International
étranger
T est une falaise solide
ici et c'est le pergélisol
c'est tellement  euh évident quand vous venez de comprendre à
quoi ressemble le changement climatique et
c'est juste dans votre visage
Je viens de la Nouvelle-Écosse J'ai vécu là-bas
toute ma vie quand je pense à l'
érosion côtière Je pense à vous savez de fortes vagues
frappant la côte et  et provoquant l'
érosion du matériau avec cette puissance
des vagues qui se produit ici aussi,
mais ce qui se passe également, c'est que la
température de l'air devient de plus en plus
chaude et de plus en plus chaude, ce qui se passe lorsque vous
augmentez bien la température de l'air,
évidemment ce pergélisol est  va
dégeler donc vous avez du pergélisol dégel
sur la côte et vous avez l'impact
des vagues
étrangères
L'océan Arctique diminue et il devient de
moins en moins chaque année et vous avez
des saisons d'eau libre plus longues que vous connaissez
dans une région où la glace était  gelé
solide à la rive pendant neuf mois par an
peut-être que maintenant vous savez même aussi peu
que sept mois et demi de
glace solide gelée alors maintenant nous avons plus d'eau et
plus de temps pour que les vagues frappent la côte
[Musique] tout
cela n'est pas consolidé  euh, vous savez des
matériaux qui peuvent être facilement emportés
et donc tout ce matériau à l'avant
ici, le sable qui a été évacué
du haut, il est tout simplement emporté par la
mer instantanément ou sur ces immenses
plages ici du du le  vagues
et puis vous vous retrouvez avec un visage propre à
nouveau, puis les choses commencent à se
détacher, puis le processus recommence à
zéro
planète
tant que le pergélisol est gelé, il
contient tout ce carbone qui est un grand
potentiel pour l  comme les gaz à effet de serre au
final mais tant que c'est gelé c'est bon
c'est là c'est sûr ça ne va
rien faire mais parce que ça tague et
c'est parce que ça va tellement vite tout
ce carbone va finir dans le système
va se dégrader ou chaland  sera
dégradé et qui sera émis sous forme de
gaz à effet de serre et renforcera ainsi
ce cycle de réchauffement
étranger
[Musique]
si vous arrêtez les vagues alors vous arrêtez la
majorité de l'érosion eh bien pensez à
Tuck Island comme une barrière naturelle à
ces vagues derrière c'est est  la
communauté que nous pensons sur la base de son
taux actuel d'érosion élévation du niveau de la mer dans les
projections d'augmentation de la température de l'air
nous pensons que l'île de tuck pourrait disparaître dans
les 18 à 25 prochaines années c'est
scientifiquement dans la vie de chacun je
regarde les données physiques que je peux
vous dire que là où se trouve la communauté là où se trouve
l'hôpital là où le euh vous savez alors que
nous approchons du cimetière dans un certain nombre de
maisons seront perdus dans la mer dans les
25 à 50 prochaines années, je peux tél  l vous que l'
élévation du niveau de la mer
augmentera automatiquement le niveau de la mer
autour de tuck afin que d'énormes parties de
la communauté soient sous l'eau pendant les
tempêtes je ne pense pas que les gens que
vous connaissez euh dans certains cas nous aurons même
le choix de rester  parce qu'il n'y
aura pas de terre sur laquelle rester, elle disparaît,
on nous dit que euh 2040
que l'île tuck n'existera plus
si nous ne faisons rien, ce qui est dans 18
ans et quand on y pense,
c'est un clin d'œil  eye
[Musique]
expliquer
est
[Musique]
étranger
Je suis né et j'ai grandi dans ma communauté de
Tuck J'ai continué à vivre ici mes enfants
vivent ici
tout le monde est lié à cette communauté d'
une manière ou d'une autre vous savez
Communauté très soudée, il est vraiment difficile de
voir que vous savez que nous pouvons perdre tout cela
dans notre emplacement qui est très unique,
nous essayons de
chercher un financement afin que nous puissions protéger
notre rivage pour nous donner plus de temps,
vous savez, pour déménager  l'avenir si
tu regardes ici tu peux  n voyez comment les
dalles de ciment commencent à se soulever,
ils ont fait leur travail, vous savez
depuis 30 40 ans,
c'est
[Musique]
mères Je veux que vous réunissiez tous vos
adolescents et que vous les rassembliez
autour de la radio Je veux vous dire un
petite histoire
qui était une fille ensemble de l'
essence
si nous faisions un pitch à ce sujet et partions
c'est un énorme problème à cause d'
une raison culturelle sentimentale il y a des
gens dans la communauté qui ne veulent
pas simplement se lever et partir
il y a un attachement il y a l'
aspect culturel un  des grandes choses que
vous savez que nous ne voulons pas faire quelque chose
comme ça, c'est que nous avons un cimetière juste
contre l'océan ici
dont nous avons besoin que nous voulons protéger aussi longtemps
que nous le pouvons,
c'est super important qu'ils
nous écoutent ici
et les grandes fosses  avec le gouvernement fédéral en
ce moment, c'est le changement climatique
il n'y a pas de meilleur exemple de
changement climatique qu'en ce moment
vous savez que mon urgence est différente de celle de
quelqu'un du sud
parce que je vis ici et je le vois
tous les jours que nous avons regardé  nous avons regardé les
vagues à l'automne et le niveau de la mer
monter et l'action des vagues qui se
produit pour voir des maisons tomber dans l'
océan
et obtenir à peine un soutien pour y faire face,
c'est ce qui me frustre à l'
étranger,
il y a tellement de choses à voir les océans arctiques
là-bas vous  savoir si vous venez en été
c'est le meilleur moment c'est un endroit vraiment riche
je ne vivrais jamais ailleurs
[Musique]
étranger
donc c'est la petite station météo a
un anémomètre de vent qui est la
direction du vent la vitesse du vent a une
température de l'air mais aussi  a une caméra en
termes de communauté c'est un
site très important il est capable de regarder la
glace de mer la fonte de la glace de mer et aussi
quand la glace de mer a disparu l'impact
des vagues et de la côte c'est une zone
où ils viennent  pour la
récolte de subsistance et pour qu'ils sachent dans quoi
ils s'embarquent, que ce soit du brouillard ou des
vagues avant de faire le Trek ici,
je pense que
c'est nous allons devoir
déplacer le
finalement comme si c'était inévitable  capable c'est triste
mais comme tu ne peux pas tu dois y
aller je suppose que si tu es comme moi et que la
plupart des gens comme eux n'aiment pas qu'on leur
dise quoi faire
alors euh ouais je pense qu'il est important que
la communauté aime a  un choix et
euh ils arrivent à
euh aider à planifier ce qu'ils veulent voir dans
leur nouvelle communauté
serré serré il
suffit de déplacer un fil et nous irons
ça marche ça marche maintenant ouais
à la fin de la journée personne ne veut
laisser
personne ne veut partir là où nous sommes aujourd'hui,
il est vraiment difficile pour nous de dire oui,
nous allons devoir
nous avons une histoire de pensionnat
et tout ce genre de choses où les gens ont
été emmenés et n'avaient plus le
choix, il est important que les
dirigeants de la communauté  éduquez notre communauté pour
qu'elle dise que tout va bien et que nous devons le faire,
mais nos gens écouteront nos gens,
nous sommes les gens qui vont
vivre dans un nouvel endroit, ça pourrait être
bien si la communauté comme vous le savez
nous dit comme ce qu'ils veulent  pour voir
leur nouvelle communauté regarder li  ke
les conversations du nord
-ouest étrangère
[Musique]
[Musique] d'
accord,
c'est en fait la première maison dans laquelle nous avons
emménagé ici qui avait de l'eau courante
qui était dans les années 60
étrangère
[Musique]
Delta
eh bien vous  peut voir où les
banques commencent à tomber prêtes à tomber
whoa Kingfisher doit couper un nid
là-dessous
est
bien nous allons bien
nous avons survécu à un autre hiver je veux dire si
quelque chose un peu d'excitation une fois par
an à droite
tout le monde a besoin d'un peu d'
excitation une fois  dans un moment donc
le Delta est
étranger
[Musique]
Usine étrangère donc ils ne descendent
plus
Je me souviens d'être venu ici quelques fois
et de tirer depuis le bateau
non c'est juste des histoires
alors pourquoi tes parents n'ont-ils pas déménagé à
Inuvik  c'est là qu'ils ont grandi
c'est là qu'ils ont gagné leur vie mon père
était un trappeur et c'était sa région et
aussi toute la question de la relocalisation est juste
comme non ce n'est pas pour nous,
vous pensez qu'il y a une chance que comme une
réaction  comme ça va arriver à
Tuck c'est leur terrain de chasse c'est
leur domaine ils se sont adaptés à ça
similaire à la façon dont nous nous sommes adaptés ici
donc la relocalisation non seulement
je me perdrais si c'était relocalisé
[Music]
étranger
un couple  des cygnes qui nichent juste là-bas,
vous devez savoir ce que vous faites
ici,
c'est
parfois triste de penser que
vous savez que nous ne nous soucions pas et qu'il est
difficile d'obtenir des baleines maintenant, je veux dire
à l'époque, les 10 familles
attendaient au moins  saison des quais à l'
étranger,
souvenez-vous que mon père était sorti
quand j'étais jeune avec un autre chasseur et
ils tiraient quelques baleines
ici
et le travail commençait, mais quand vous avez
terminé, vous êtes prêt à rentrer à la maison et vous êtes bon
pour  l'hiver encore ce ne sont que des
souvenirs que
nous ne voyons plus que le
changement climatique est très important ici
mais ce n'est pas un
changement dans le sens où tout
était stable et maintenant tout est
changé
[Musique]
si vous vivez avec
Transformation perpétuelle t  puis
ce qui se passe avec le changement climatique n'est
pas si radicalement différent
[Musique]
il y a des écrivains indigènes
qui disent que je suis le changement climatique pour
les peuples indigènes
ce n'est pas une apocalypse imminente après une
longue histoire de stabilité et de bonheur
mais l'apocalypse pour les peuples indigènes
c'est déjà arrivé
[Musique]
ils ne sont pas confrontés au changement climatique à
partir d'une position où tout allait bien
et maintenant tout à coup il y a un problème mais
ils font face au changement climatique à
partir d'une position dans laquelle nous vivons
ils disent que nos ancêtres  post-apocalypse
l'appareil photo
le
code solaire japonais
est
étranger
Le meilleur scénario pour la relocalisation je pense qu'il
est temps que nous ayons le temps maintenant et nous avons le
temps de dire aux gens que vous connaissez
euh à quoi ressemble la relocalisation
pour vous et et à quoi ressemblerait un futur tuck
on dirait que
tu parles de choses comme ça tu
dois avoir un certain nombre de personnes à bord en
ce moment dans ma position ça a été ça a
été une bataille pour que nous puissions
trouver une stratégie  egic plan pour l'avenir mais
en même temps nous devons être agressifs
et intelligents à ce sujet pour nous assurer qu'il
y aura un endroit appelé tuck à un
moment donné dans le futur
[Musique]
merci
s'il vous plaît
garder le
destin
étranger étranger
[Musique]
l'environnement  est en train de changer mais nous pouvons nous
adapter, nous serons toujours là, vous
savez, nous sommes des gens résilients et euh, le
changement n'est pas nouveau pour nous